ready for this let's do it
so we'll cut
the German long sword my name is Colton
Arias I'm 18 years old I really love
making something that's going to last
for a really long time and it's also
really fun to hit stuff on fire
the German long story traces its roots
back to 14th century Europe
this two-handed weapon was powerful
enough to deliver deadly blows and its
double-edged blade inflict deep wounds
and slashes against any enemy that came
across its path
the massive blade was so powerful that
skilled Warriors had to train
extensively in the art of long sword
fencing to master its strength while
this weapon was no longer used in combat
longsword fencing is practiced around
the world today
the Cora
my name is Liam Hoffman I'm a 19 year
old bladesmith from North Carolina most
people won't take me seriously because
of my age I would love to prove them
wrong
the chorus sword originated in Nepal
where it was wielded for Centuries by a
legendary group of soldiers the gurkas
the gurkhas were known for their
Fearless military prowess of
weapons-based martial arts which
included symbolic Weaponry like the
corusaur this fearsome sword features a
long curved blade that flares outward at
the tip maximizing the force of each
swing and making it an ideal weapon for
both slashing and chopping also used in
sacrifice a skilled Cora wielder could
reportedly cut a sheep in half with just
one swing
from experience I know the greatest
challenge with any long sword build
especially if I'm doing it out of
Damascus is going to be keeping it
straight and making sure the temper and
the heat treat are spot on so it does
not break plenty of things can go wrong
when you're clenching a sword it could
crack it could warp it could fracture
let's hope none of that happens because
everything is riding on this quench
awesome perfect
this thing is massive in a boat like
this a million things can go wrong if
you make one false step or try to rush
it too much you could ruin the whole
thing in the last step or in the first
step I'm completely done with the sword
fit and finish is damn near perfect
that's a legendary sword
I've never made any blade this long
before so it's going to be an adventure
I'm gonna try to stay pretty
historically accurate
I'm gonna be forging Damascus and having
that Damascus on a large blade will
really be pretty cool
we're made
as I'm forging out the Damascus I'm
realizing it's way too big and I can't
actually hold it correctly because it's
too long everything about this big
Billet is taking a lot of time me
Swinging it from the forge to the press
and drawing it out and waiting for it to
heat up
unfortunately I don't have a heat
treating oven large enough so I'm gonna
have to do this in the propane Forge
yeah this sword is at least twice as big
as I'm used to I would not normally heat
treat something like this
hopefully this thing heats up evenly
okay go for the quench
it's perfectly straight it's really
hardened and now I'm going to sharpen it
and then I'll do my testing
works pretty good that looks cool my
plan for the handle is to square
everything up first add my layout lines
and then slowly work it down into an
oval
I'm adding in a few bronze spacers to
match the bronze finial and add in some
Fullers for grip and books
so this thing's pretty cool it's the
first finial I've made the sword Has
Come Together really well and it is
really awesome
well it's Miss welcome to the strength
test the throne chop
in order to test the strength of your
Edge as well as the overall construction
of your German lung swords I'll be
bashing them into this Throne Colton
you're up first you ready for this let's
do it all right
[Music]
thank you
all right Colton this is a it's a great
looking blade man I like your Damascus
pattern it's still nice and straight
didn't take much damage Beyond a slight
glinting so well done thank you
gentlemen to test the strength of your
Korra I'm going to take one blow into
these skulls you ready yeah okay
foreign
it feels really nice in the hand you did
a great job on this handle obviously we
pretty much took care of that skull
now this thing once you get it started
it's going to go right my only worry is
stopping it yeah you don't always have
to have a heavy blade to make a heavy
blow
but it's a beautiful piece it's a nice
job thank you well done this is the
sharpness test the cowhide bag slice
called New York first you ready for this
let's do it let's do this
[Music]
all right Carlton your Edge Cuts cleanly
it's razor sharp in thrusting drawing it
back and cutting the balance is good and
overall sir
it will cut thank you
The Nepalese Cora was a blade that had a
distinct inward curve and a spatulated
flare at the tip making it a weapon for
slicing and chopping I will cut across
these sandbags let's see how sharp your
blades are you ready yeah
when he said it this was Heavy you
weren't kidding this is a chopper a
little hard to control on The Recoil but
not enough to where I can't wield it
this sir will cut
great good job
forged in fire war of weapons